malala yosef sai it is time to take
action outspoken critic of the taliban
the youngest nobel peace prize laureate
tireless campaigner for girls education
mark international women's day malala
met with the economist's editor-in-chief
zanny minton bedos to discuss the
effects of conflict on girls education
[Music]
right now i'm sure you along with all of
us are watching with horror the the
scenes in ukraine a country that you
know
only a couple of weeks ago was was a
peaceful european country and suddenly
there are extraordinary pictures of kids
as refugees kids in bomb shelters what
goes through your mind when you see that
it is heartbreaking to see
these images of
people collecting their belongings and
leaving their homes uh and i always tell
people that
becoming a refugee is no one's first
choice it's always the last and it's
always the only option that they have
left and we see that in ukraine right
now and
and and we all know that wars cause
uh
irreversible and unimaginable damage but
i think it's really important for all of
us to realize that we need to come
together and ask for an end to these
wars whether that is in yemen whether
that is in palestine whether that is in
kashmir or
afghanistan or in ukraine or any other
country right now is there a message
that you would have for the young people
of ukraine right now
i want to tell
everyone in ukraine especially
young girls that
you know we stand with you and none of
this is your fault and this should not
be happening and i hope that this is
also a time of
awakening for all of us about
how these conflicts affect so many
countries like when you look at
afghanistan or other countries you know
these countries were not always poor and
these countries were not always in these
crisis something happened abruptly and
things changed the same was the story of
swat valley as well it was a place of
tourism and the queen was visiting and
we you know we had a good economy and
then all of a sudden people appear with
guns and bombs and and you are like
what's happening in these words like
things get so complicated that
uh you know that in the end you just
sort of forget to ask this basic
question which is why is this happening
why can't we put an end to these
conflicts uh so i hope that you know
that it wakes us up is there anything
that we've learned from the pandemic and
the ability to do remote learning the
improvements in technology that can be
helpful for children of conflict in
future i think uh there are
opportunities but there are challenges
as well in digital education i think we
need to take full advantage of it but
also
ensure that we are
addressing the gender gap in access to
digital tools some of the research work
that we have done in nigeria and
in pakistan showed us that girls are
less likely to have access to digital
tools
in their homes especially when there's
one digital device it's more likely that
the boy has access to it or even if she
has access to it she's more busy in the
house chores and she does not get enough
time to be to be learning and studying
when leaders make policies for digital
education they have to ensure that
they make gender-inclusive policies for
the digital education future that we see
can we turn out to afghanistan which is
another i mean almost unfathomable
humanitarian tragedy and at the same
time
a government that clearly does not share
your views on
girls education
how does the malala fund operate there
at this point so malala fund
was supporting activists in afghanistan
and in this critical times you have to
ensure that they are safe
and because of that association with
malala fund a lot of them uh were in a
very difficult situation so
most of them are now based in different
countries or have uh found refuge in in
in their final destination now uh and
all of them are still engaging in
advocacy for girls education for women's
rights and protection right now and we
support them
regarding afghanistan this is a time
where
one leaders can show whether they are
truly committed to girls education or
not afghanistan right now is the only
country where girls are facing
difficulties in their secondary
education they
they are basically facing a de facto ban
on their secondary education
and the taliban will continue to make
excuses from lack of female teachers or
safety issues on their way to schools to
prevent girls from getting back into
schools so we need to ensure that those
children can enroll back into schools
and that the girls who will be returning
back to school that they receive quality
education what is deeply concerning is
that the curriculum plans that we see
already from the taliban they are taking
out some of the key subjects and we need
to ensure that you know children are
learning about sciences and social
studies so we need to ensure that the
education that they get is quality
education how do you think western
policymakers can really influence that i
mean what are their tools that you think
are not being used approaches that are
not being used because at the moment
everyone
seems almost helpless at watching this
i think you know right now there are
just so many things that need to happen
because we know that
afghanistan
is is is literally
you know on the verge of a collapse an
economic collapse right now
and i hope that first of all these
international communities
in all of the conversations and
dialogues that they're having with the
taliban that they make no compromise on
the protection of
women's rights girls education and
minorities rights that has to be their
top priority and i think along with that
there is need for financing
there's need for humanitarian fund uh
but
there's also the issue of uh of you know
this this traditional definition of
humanitarian fund that does not include
education so there's another push to uh
encourage these leaders to help in
education as well to ensure that we are
actually helping the afghanistan
communities and and people to
actually be prepared for their future
and to rebuild their economy and i hope
that president biden and the u.s courts
they
make
um
they make just decisions for the
afghan reserves you know that money
belongs to the afghan people and it
should go back to them it should be
helping them in recovering from this
crisis like we know that millions of
afghan people
are
at risk of starvation
we know that many of them are you know
are right now selling their daughters to
help their families to
survive
so when you see these kind of news it
breaks your heart uh because you know
that this is not the life that they
should be facing right now and this is
something that
they that
the western countries or other
neighboring countries that could prevent
and i would also add that there is a
strong role for the muslim countries to
play in this time right now
the rule is critical i hope that oic and
other muslim countries together stand up
for the protection of women and girls
because the taliban basically misuse the
name of islam so other muslim countries
need to stand up and say that
in their countries which are a dozen
there are dozens of muslim countries
that in their countries
women have access to education they do
jobs they go to work they don't need a
male companion to go from one city to
another uh they can earn f for
themselves uh and and i think you know
they need to define
what it means in islam to have equality
for women to have education for for
girls so
they need to challenge the taliban
quality education
is urgent it is important
it is important for peace and stability
it is important for democracy it is
important for making informed decisions
uh and it is
important for our own empowerment and
self-care as well thanks for watching if
you'd like to find out more about our
forthcoming subscriber events or watch
previous discussions please click the
link
see you next time